a group herbage it's a giant in the
field of astronomy and physics one of
the Giants of the kind of transformation
of astronomy in the 20th century into a
major branch of physics Marga Burbage
was an observational astronomer she was
one of the pioneers actually in stellar
spectroscopy and understanding elemental
abundances and stars and hand-in-glove
with that were the observations in
high-energy astronomy x-ray astronomy
and also the observations of QSOs who
quasi stellar objects of quasars every
now and then truly fortunate I come
across some astronomical image that she
made she was perhaps you know the
foremost astronomer of the of the 20th
century and her influence is still being
felt today where do the elements come
from and how do you prove where they
come from well it took some time to sort
out to get it right to know that well
they're made in stars and the Burbidge
Burbidge Fowler and Hoyle paper it was
the first and still is the most
important that's ever been written on
that subject giving you the cookbook for
how do you make the elements and why the
team of Fowler and Fred Hoyle another
British astrophysicist and Geoff
Burbidge and Margaret Burbidge really
set the stage for understanding where
the elements come from and and again
brokering this very deep relationship
between observational astronomy in
nuclear physics they figured out how you
add things like neutrons especially that
they add on a neutronic and make it into
an isotope work and make it into an
extra neutron which decays by beta decay
and becomes a new element we now
understand that most of the elements
essentially heavier than than lithium
were manufactured in the interiors of
stars or in in cosmic ray interactions
associated with supernova so that's a
pretty remarkable thing and that that
that work itself continues to this day
well I think Margaret's main
contribution other than being one of the
first great women astronomers around
observational astronomers was going
after distant galaxies and other
galaxies trying to understand what was
going on there got into redshifts of
galaxies and understanding the expansion
of the universe Margaret burbage and
Geoff Burbidge they were both known
especially Margaret for work on the
spectroscopy and and morphology of quasi
stellar objects and that helped to
establish that these things were indeed
probably supermassive black holes and
material was falling into them and again
that's what the gravitational energy
being released as this material was
heated as it approached the the black
hole and and that's kind of our working
model now for what these things are one
big project that Margaret had a big hand
in is the faint object spectrograph on
the Hubble Space Telescope so Cass
always into this day retains this this
kind of soup to nuts approach to the
subject in other words there are
theorists here and are people who work
on hardware and everything in between
well I came here a long time ago 40
years ago or more and Margaret was here
as one of the great astronomer x' and so
was fun every once a while to go down
and talk to her about what was going on
or I had a question how in the heck do
these galaxies work as
I came here from the field of
high-energy physics not astronomy so I
had a lot to learn and I could go down
and talk to her every once in a while
about galaxies and stuff like that she
was also a great source her library in
that she had subscriptions to all the
scientific journals that we were
interested in and we didn't have
subscriptions to so you go down that Oh
Margaret can I borrow this and she was
very particular okay but put a note down
there because I want that back I want to
know who had it so okay that's fair I
was first hired to assist Jeff Burbidge
and Margaret Burridge was his wife Jeff
was a character but Margaret I think was
his match the Burbidge is used to go I
guess to France every summer for about a
month and so it's there anything I can
really do to help you guys while you're
gone and so Margaret kind of got a
plenty little smile on her face and she
said oh yeah she says you can clean off
Jeff's task while we're gone but don't
tell him I told you to do that Jeff's
desk was like piled high when Jeff and
Margaret got back from Paris his test
was cleaned off and he just kind of went
through the roof and so Jeff was what
who did this Hawaii you know and so well
Margaret told me to do that she was just
the sweetest most wonderful person
Willey father would take us sabbaticals
apparently every or would spend the
summers in Cambridge I think working
with Fred Hoyle but he met the Burbidge
is there he wanted to bring Margaret to
Caltech as a postdoc it turned out that
the Astronomy Department at Caltech
didn't really want to hire a woman as
they claimed they didn't have the right
facilities on the mountain for that so
he cooked up an arrangement with the
some of the astronomers there and so
what he did is he had a he had a postdoc
available in the Kellogg radiation
laboratory at Caltech which was a
nuclear physics lab so he hired Margaret
in that position
and they hired Jeff is the astronomer
well I got to know her because of course
since I worked in nucleosynthesis and
Margaret was here that was one of the
first people I wanted to get to know I
was hard in the chemistry department but
to do what was called cosmochemistry
still it's called cosmochemistry which
is basically the origin of planets and
elements in the elements part was pure
Margaret and I never met her and so when
the time came that I worked up my nerve
to come over and meet her and was good
because it's the Center for Astrophysics
and space science was already here and I
think at the time she was chair of it
little by little she told me how their
files are handled and helped with the
process at the University of California
and I said Oh mom well that was good to
know and somehow by the time I walked
out the door I was in charge of handling
everyone's files and reviews you know
and how it was John that she had talked
me into doing and I didn't somehow
notice she was so gentle and kind and
quiet that I didn't realize I was
stepping into her job I know my wife
taught third grade and she had a little
contest there and she my wife made up
the prize would be able to go to UCSD
and speak to Margaret she did my wife
did this without telling me about it but
that's a whole nother story anyway so
two young women won this to third grade
girls and they came down and Margaret
was very wonderful she spoke to them and
talked to him and they were very excited
to talk to her and I thought it was a
great idea for the young girls to get an
opportunity to meet a female scientist
who was very famous and maybe inspire
them a little bit Margaret happy
birthday and thank you for everything
happy birthday Margaret Margaret happy
birthday happy hundredth birthday I'm
very proud to have known you and
congratulations not only on the birthday
but most of all for your career coming
here from Chicago where you already were
a legacy there that was one of the
highlights of coming here was having the
chance to meet Margaret Burbidge and
here's to you Margaret happy birthday
[Music]
you
[Music]